sur le fond demandé que les
parlementaires qui paraît une
candidature adhèrent aux valeurs de la
droite et du centre les parlementaires
sans les centristes peuvent parrainer
parlementaires centristes peuvent
parrainer si on nous explique demain que
les parlementaires centristes peuvent
pas parrainer as moi ça fait exploser le
système est un moment si on se fout de
la règle des primaires
à un moment il finira par y avoir des
candidats en dehors des primaires il
faut tout de même que aux républicains
en ayant été atteint oui oui parce que
quatre soit la règle est respectée et je
vais revenir là dessus
dans son esprit et dans sa forme et des
statuts ça se respecte
quand il ya quelques moi j'entends un de
mes collègues au bureau politique de
l'ump
à l'époque encore expliqué les statuts
on s'en fout on est là pour faire la
politique
quand mardi soir nicolas sarkozy me
répond mais hervé on n'est pas là pour
faire du juridisme jeudi faut faire
gaffe
il ya un niveau d'adaptation qui est
convenable je me suis abstenu je vais
vous dire pourquoi mais il ya un niveau
au delà duquel l'irrespect de la règle
commencerez à poser de saccharose la
guerre sommes là et visibles crédibilité
politique c'est pas que ça m'agace c'est
que c'est un vrai sujet c'est quelque
chose que vous semblez arrivée hummer la
primaire n'a de sens que pour autant que
la règle soit solide et celui de la
respecte